[Music]
hi conan o'brien here i love my job and
i really love my fans i love to spend
more time with them but as you can see
i'm very busy
anyway
i decided how can i meet fans spend time
with them without actually being there
that's when i thought of the cone drone
cone drone get in here
like you to get out there and make a
meaningful connection with one of my
fans get to it
[Music]
hello
hello fan i'm conan o'brien and i'm
ready to hang out with you okay i guess
that's great this will be fun hey watch
my lamp here you go fan your very own
conan autograph oh thank you
here you go fan your very own conan
autograph thank you here you go fan your
very own conan autograph thanks here you
go fan your very own conan autograph
it was 1998 and i had interviewed every
single golden girl except estelle getty
i had to get her but how will i find out
where she got her car washed see and i
waited there and i posed as one of the
guys that dries the car and the producer
tells me we have no guests for tonight
well we're all in a panic we don't know
what to do so i go to the commissary who
do i run into buying chili alissa milano
i'm like this is perfect hey did i ever
tell you about the time i interviewed
owen wilson
the guy has really dry hands he doesn't
moisturize he looks like a mummy anyway
i said to him owen moisturize your hands
and he said you're thinking about my
brother i'm like oh yeah
[Music]
van where are you conan fan
i know you're here somewhere
there you are you silly rascal the stock
market fell and then got back up again
six times today the stock market is
acting like me after three appletinis
oh yeah actually two absolutely
a mentholated cough drop
i am gone
[Laughter]
vick's vaporub just put me over
well i feel pretty good i got to make a
real personal connection today so rod
todd it was very nice meeting you i hope
you enjoyed meeting
my face
on someone else's body
you